joining me is celebrity hair stylist and
Tresemme spokesperson Lacey Redway and
we partnered with Tresemme and Lacey
lacing who has been backstage all so
long giving a hair refresh to a busy mom
of two Julissa LaFontaine now we do have
a before I think she looks gorgeous did
you see an opportunity to create like
more fluidity to the hair yeah so Jalisa
has naturally long hair which is a
perfect Contender to create fluid
movement so that's exactly what we did
we want to reduce frizz and add
hydration so yeah let's check it out all
right well I'm very excited to see the
final look come on out Julissa
foreign
oh my gosh and I'm sorry but
it smells so good
wow I have to say it this is it's money
so Julissa how do you feel I feel
confident I have two kids so what I
found myself was that which is wearing a
lot of low Sleek ponytails High buns so
my husband is gonna love this look
um oh I wear my hair naturally curly
like what you guys saw in the before
picture which I really love but curly
hair tends to be drier Tangled Up really
easily so what I noticed when Lacey was
using the new Tresemme line was that she
was using the tonic and a detangler with
finger like you didn't have to use a
comb instantly exactly and it added a
really good amount of moisture it smells
amazing like what you said and it has
really in for one really great movement
like
[Applause]
you can achieve this look at home by
like using the prone Fusion fluid tonic
it adds hydration it adds shine we
didn't have to use any iron to achieve
this look and it looks no irons in this
hair no no
just controlling her hair oh wow I'm
glad you mentioned that because I would
have thought this was an iron all the
way no no no so all you need to do is
use a prune Fusion fluid tonic on damp
hair you pin set your hair overnight and
in the morning you shake it out and it
just moves fluid like water well I'm
solved
everyone in our
are going to go home with the Tresemme
Pro infusion smooth collection of
shampoo
[Music]